hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play condemned
criminal origins are the reason I do
that is because um why that happens
every time I load up is because and my
save might my start fraps key is f9
which is probably stupid alright anyway
so got some here Chris
ready whoa what done some ghostbusters
actually going on here
OOP huh what is this crazy kooky CSI
chemical composition oh you do that lady
no liquid is c41 color photo developer
fluid oh shutter box who develop their
own color shots no good for to the
middle of your own no record all right
so wait these photos were processed here
somewhere within the station that would
be my gas about digital photos you got
all this amazing technology and a pipe
look at whatever yeah dun ennemi with
Tasers ah hey where'd you go wow wow
phaser across there we go oh wait hang
on I didn't grab your weapon hey honest
I'm on that crowbar
Lulu oh that's real effective buddy how
about this big ha ha
Oh give me your Gary Oh Oh what now
buddy hahaha I just killed you I'm a cop
you didn't see anything yeah yeah where
am I going
what am i doing what am i doing besides
looking at these was there another thing
that I needed over here ah yeah I'm
never lettin this crowbar out of my
sight
game saved whoa hello uh hi hey how
about no rebars that what oh luck I'll
block you ha you did
er no oh oh
goo great googly moogly we destroyed him
but I know why there's such a delay from
using the Taser to actually being able
to swing I mean kind of defeats the
purpose in a way alright nice little
shop here we got healthcare Ariel
I see I know my picture was covering the
health bar if I haven't changed it then
it's still covering if I was able to
change it it's on the other side now so
ha ha ha
all right let's hear so far not very
spooky it was it nope
what yes no why don't I just want to rip
pipes off the wall what kind of
destructive cop em I kind of murders
random people that run up to me
hello no no hear what the this is all in
event one well that'd be quiet you're
not searching more properly destroying
your apartment
they'd have no faith in you but I am
innocent
yeah uh-huh no you have a special talent
I give you I'm moving here we haven't oh
I can't go that way
how's weird hello anybody in here
l-o-l oh hi what god what what what
they'll do
how what hey wait a minute not
that that what Oh what
hi is that supposed to happen you coming
the other way now you're gonna use the
door
yeah actually gonna use the door buddy
ah what ah damn it he was going right
for me how how what the how why huh how
oh no uh-uh
give me those thank you pop some pills
here God he went right through the wall
I think that was supposed to happen uh
I'm not just assuming it was a giant bug
and he just somehow managed to finagle
his way through I think what's going on
with people how are they how are they
able to do that that's what I want to
know
keep away Yeah right what do you mean
sledgehammer required sledgehammer
you're facing and dizzy move object what
do all ah I thought that was gonna be a
point to that like a vent never mind
I'm very confused I don't know what I
knew things are starting to start
getting weird but hello anybody here
anybody here
TV yep that's one strong TV good with
that no yes no pipe no pouch one where
where am I am I lose some office
building or something and there's
another thing over here I want to make
sure I check out everything up here
because I know I'm gonna miss stuff
besides that this is this oh there's a
sledgehammer oh okay I get it I get it I
get I got to go around anyway I gots to
go around I'll be back just give me a
sec just a sec why can't I open this one
nope okay I got to go all the way around
get a stupid sledgehammer cuz apparently
a crowbar can't break that door down
dan jell-o's what D'Angelo's is some
pizza place I'm thoroughly confused
what
hello ooh a shout gun a shout gun oh you
don't want to mess with me and my shout
Kenya I had to drop I can only carry one
thing at a time
really you're way too melee with this
whoops Ellis
I like how I whoa hello hi there hey
buddy you got a pistol there oh yeah Wow
well episode didn't hurt oh look swing
what about Cal I can check the ammo by
doing that I'm out this has no bullets
cha cha what what whoa
hi don't even think about it
Hey hi guy oh yeah
I saw that I saw you I saw you where'd
you go yeah Oh bringing the pain Oh time
for the pain train I guess maybe if
somebody there is someone there hey hey
hey don't break the TV at the to sting
to do Wow okay now oh they become
stunned until I hit them
useful vital information for your
everyday life whoops yeah Wow what you
know right in your fat face Oh
usually the way that the mêlée works in
the game it really looks like it
freaking hurts what the hell
and it oh I don't want the mannequin arm
no I don't want to use that good god no
absolutely not no no no no no no
absolutely no goodness gracious
what is it thinking Oh
I've gone no thank you
things uh things got a little weird
quiet it's quiet now they came from the
blackness anybody home is anybody there
yeah
crowbar required you son mother all
right
fine fine fine Jesus Kali I swear
can't get it got anything done right
around here can't get anything done
right I swear this is just a pain in the
buttocks and I will not stand for it
yeah no using it where did I put that
crowbar stuff like over here or
something aah oh I got to go all the way
back for the crow by then probably
anything worth it and then it probably
gonna be like sledgehammer required for
the next one and I got to go back again
cuz I can't hold two things at once
cuz we're all hyperrealism wait there's
another sledgehammer oh I dropped this
crowbar back of the shout gun god I
can't get anything right I can't get a
damn a Dern dang damn thing right there
it is
golly I swear do I move faster now that
I have this nope still achingly this
this cop is so out of shape oh man worst
cop ever
this guy is probably one of the guys and
you know in men in black in that first
opening scene with Will Smith they're
the ones that couldn't keep up with him
yeah this is the guy
oh he's lucky he's got me watching over
his shoulder or watching through his
neck
okay now back into the creepy basement
back into the creepy basement now I'm
not ready for anything down here anybody
anybody okay
what
really really really really really how
much AMRO I got three I got three am
Rose Thomas speaking hi hi that no one
how do you know this number anyway
I know many things about you in creepy
did your mother's death I've watched you
obey me with I'm your potential even my
potential yes you become an excellent
investigator a through training or luck
but instinctually however if you'll find
that you are capable of seeing so much
more huh again with the instincts right
there gift from well perhaps from God
remember they can help you and other
okay again I must go be careful
yeah don't tell me what to do I got a
shotgun I don't need to be careful
anymore but ah my life I hate my life
and my love Oh
King bird carcass well isn't that nice I
hear birds now why is the birds dead
well hello
that's a hang on I got a deal with this
this a hole here
- - teacher hunter what where where you
go alright fine what the oh you're back
now huh you'll stick around this time
Vegeta ah ha ha ha yeah nice shot
uh-oh missed what them how time fam'ly
beat you to death first
nope miss oh oh oh yeah I'm so pro I'm
so pro this I'm gonna use a shotgun
forever you see at all so problem
Oh God mmm gee alright so anyway there's
a decaying bird carcass that I need to
find for some reason sounds important oh
whoa ah I see it yeah yeah I'll just
I'll pick that up
cuz that's you know that's good that's a
good thing it's a good thing
all right I am actually all out of time
so I will wrap it up here thank you all
so much for watching click the
annotations for more videos that I've
done in the past and more Let's Plays
thank you again for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye